[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled getting into
the brain
the ethics of invasive human
neuroscience research this webinar is
part of the 10th annual neuroscience
virtual event and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots so
let's get started before we begin i want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during this presentation
you can find this live chat located at
the right of your screen now you can
also participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education
credits link located at the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr ashley
feinsinger
dr feinstein is an adjunct assistant
professor in the department of medicine
at the affiliated faculty department of
philosophy at ucla for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr vine singer welcome you may
now begin your presentation
hi everyone um
i wanted to take a moment to thank lab
roots and the nih brain initiative for
having me here today to talk about the
ethics of invasive human neuroscience
research
i think neuroethics is a really
important topic to talk about in the
context of cross-cutting impacts of
scientific collaboration and i'm quite
happy to be able to share some of the
collaborations i've been a part of today
and some of the results and the work of
those team efforts
so um an outline of what we'll chat
about today is we'll start by giving a
broad overview of invasive human
neuroscience research and particularly
the types of research that my lab is
interested in
will survey the ethical issues at the
forefront of that research
i will present an initial framework for
developing best practices in the space
and some of the collaborative work that
we've done with investigators across the
country
i'll share some participant narratives
and motivate the importance of having
that perspective as well and answering
some of these ethical questions
and i'll end with sharing the next steps
for some of the projects we're doing and
talk a little bit about how my team
approaches collaborative neuroethics
research
the learning objectives will be
by the end of the session we'll be able
to explain the fundamental ethical
challenges of basic
human neuroscience research
and we'll be able to evaluate research
practices against two leading ethical
principles
the first is maintaining the integrity
of clinical care in space and the second
is ensuring the voluntariness of
participation
so i want to just start by acknowledging
my incredible lab members you'll see
them at the top
my lab works on the ethics of basic
human neuroscience research and we ask
questions about consent why participants
join these types of studies what
participants value and in general what
risks are permissible to subject
participants to for the sake of
answering questions about the brain and
so to this end we really do work in
close collaboration with philosophers
neuroscientists neurosurgeons and
behavioral decision making experts to
answer these questions in a
collaborative way and we use a variety
of different methodologies including
qualitative and quantitative methods as
well as the tools of philosophy so
conceptual analysis and things like that
and hopefully um we'll be able to see
some of those methods throughout the
talk today um i want to also thank you
to the brain initiative who funds my lab
and to dr nader perattian who's my co-pi
and
you know this work wouldn't have been
possible without this really fantastic
team
so the kinds of research that my lab
focuses on is basic intracranial human
neuroscience studies so this is
research that is aimed at understanding
the fundamental workings of the human
brain so research that is not guided by
providing a clinical benefit a
therapeutic benefit to participants but
instead guided by really answering a
scientific question understanding the
brain
and
it involves recording or stimulation
inside the human skull
these studies are conducted in close
concert with neurosurgical interventions
and in fact they currently require the
involvement of neurosurgical patients so
patients with implanted wires or devices
for clinical reasons
these patients really provide
researchers with an opportunity to peer
into the brain in ways that would
otherwise not be ethically permissible
right and part of that is because most
of the risk of
intracranial recordings and modulation
is already assumed in a in a clinical
environment for these patients so here's
just a kind of survey of the types of
studies that we might be interested in
when we're talking about the space
so first in one you have an example of a
of a patient who may have an rns device
and researchers may take advantage of
that device by
simply taking extra cord extra
recordings from it in a lab setting
second researchers might record through
modifications of clinically indicated
implants or wires right for research
purposes so this might be if a patient
is um having wires placed for
recordings during a emu stay so an
epilepsy monitoring unit stay
researchers might modify those wires a
bit so that they could record and learn
about
individual neurons firing something like
that
in the third case researchers may record
through extra temporary electrodes that
are placed onto a patient's brain say
during a deep brain stimulation device
surgery so a patient who has parkinson's
for example who may be undergoing
surgery for a dbs device
would then consent to do extra tasks in
the operating room
so researchers could answer some basic
questions about the brain learn about
movement learn about memory stuff like
that
and in four we have a little bit of a
different scenario but it falls within
the scope of this this kind of research
is research conducted as part of an
investigational device trial or that
makes use of a utah array that's
implanted say as part of a bci study
i think it's important to look not just
at the studies through the kind of lens
of looking at the technology and looking
at the brain but to also look at the
study through the lens of the patient
right so here are some of the examples
of participants who make these studies
possible so in the first column we have
an example of a participant who has an
rns device who is also
using a mobile brain monitoring device
that works in conjunction with the rns
system
um and who may come to the lab to do
various movement tasks for researchers
and two you have an example of a patient
who's participating in basic science
research during their epilepsy
monitoring unit stay
and three you have a patient who is
moving a joystick as part of basic
science research during their dbs
surgery and in four you have an example
of a patient in a part of a bci trial
who is playing the piano using neural
brain control based on basic science
decoding principles right the
derived from kind of ongoing research
and i think these four types of research
are are different and we'll talk about
their differences in a second but um
they're also united by three things so
they share the goal of understanding
basic science questions about the brain
there is an absence of near-term
therapeutic benefit right so not only is
it the case that these types of studies
aren't really aimed at providing these
particular patients with benefits but
many of these studies aren't
you know they may be exploratory they
may not even really be kind of at the
stage where there's a kind of
foreseeable clinical benefit in the near
future
and three all of these studies again
make use of intracranial recordings and
stimulations in subjects who either have
a clinical need for a neurosurgical
intervention or whose condition allows
them to undergo one for the sake of a
study
so as invasive technical capabilities
advance right so as we improve our
neurotechnology our implants our
recording possibilities and as we learn
more about the brain and the conditions
that these techniques can address there
will be more and more patients with
these devices in their heads and um
they'll be in more parts of the brain
and thus provide us with more
opportunities for research
which i think is a really wonderful
thing but it also really kind of
highlights
how important it is to ask ethical
questions about this research at this
point in time
so here is the broadest ethical question
we could ask and the one that my lab is
really interested in
should we utilize these opportunities to
study the brain
and i think you know depending on the
audience i think maybe the audience that
i'm speaking to today there may be a
resounding kind of yes of course
um and i i don't disagree with that um
so perhaps the question is a slightly
modified one maybe it's something like
um
when should we utilize these
opportunities or under what conditions
what are the constraints right what
types of things do we need to be
responsive to ethically as we utilize
these opportunities and i want to draw
your attention to two things
um
the first is that as you look at these
pictures together you know from my
perspective the thing that strikes me as
i look at these pictures and i think
about the ethics question the thing that
stands out to me is risk right and a
particular type of risk risk of physical
harm to the brain
and i think that's a very important
question to ask when we talk about the
neural ethics of these studies
and you might think that's a question
for
neurosurgeon a neuroscientist after all
you know i'm a philosopher i don't know
quite a lot about you know the risks of
a wire and a per you know particular
part of the brain and it's very much an
empirical question
what are the possible risks
for the patients in in these studies but
um
notice
two points the first is that
physical risks in terms of their
importance for ethics are always
assessed in relation to benefits right
so the question about risk is not just
what risks are there and how likely are
they to happen but it's also how
important are those risks to us as a
society to the patients themselves what
benefits are worth what risks and that
is very much not purely an empirical
question that is a question that
you know
requires an understanding of our values
as a society
and the second point
is that as the physical risks of harm to
the brain get smaller as we improve our
techniques and improve our surgical
capabilities
other ethical questions kind of come to
the forefront and so we're going to have
to grapple with a wide range of
questions even if risks keep getting
less and less of some of these
interventions
so
as a way to kind of make very salient
how
how complex answering this ethical
question is i like to use this chart and
i like to walk through it a little bit
to think about
the differences between all the studies
we just looked at and how you might
think about the different dimensions of
ethics in the space um so this is a
chart um this is something my lab's been
working on for a while it's not complete
it doesn't represent a full scope of of
the important features of these studies
but it's the start so you might walk you
know up and down you'll see
types of
categories or features of studies that
we think are really ethically important
and then going across left to right some
examples of the sub questions you might
ask to figure out
where does your study fit right where
did your study fit and how might that
affect what you need to think about as
you're designing consent or as you're
recruiting patients for example so we
can take a little walk through this
chart um i won't spend too much time on
it but um i'll go rather quickly
so first we just talked about risks and
how complex that is for thinking about
ethics um but you might think
let's look at it from the different
types of studies the kinds of risks are
different if you have a kind of chronic
implant patient with an rns system
that's coming to the lab to perform
research tasks or whether you have a
patient in an intraoperative setting
different kinds of risk the rns patient
maybe has almost no extra surgical risk
for doing the research because they're
out of the surgical context they already
have the implant but they might um drain
their battery faster they might have to
pause their therapy
you know depending on the timing of the
research and that's a kind of risk that
deserves you know serious consideration
um questions about uncertainties so we
know in
intraoperative research so a patient has
a getting a dbs
um device put in their brain and they
will kind of pause or at the end of that
spend 30 minutes now doing research
tests so they might move a joystick or
look at a screen
as part of that task
well we know that extra time in the
operating room kind of increases
surgical risks infections stuff like
that but how much time correlates with
how much risk is a difficult thing to
quantify and a difficult thing to
communicate to patients so how uncertain
are those risks and how might that
affect your practices
um
as we kind of walk down this chart
benefit it's a really important category
and it also has quite a lot of nuance
right so all of the studies i opened
you know i opened with by saying they're
non-therapeutic so they don't offer
clinical benefits to patients right
so any risks that patients take on it's
for the sake of knowledge about the
brain to learn stuff about the brain
well are there other types of benefits
are there non-clinical benefits for the
studies and that might change depending
on which study you're in
um
how closely related
is the knowledge of the research to the
patient's own condition that might
matter right so you could imagine a
patient who has parkinson's
but the research that they're
participating in has to do with memory
right not necessarily has to do with
understanding how movement works and
that might matter to thinking about how
to talk with the patient and how to
treat them
differences in participant population
right so the
the patients who participate in this
research have a wide range of diagnoses
and that is um expanding we know that
dbs
is you know in the research phases for
treatment refractory depression
it's approved for ocd but it's also
being researched for things like chronic
low back pain and how do chronic low
back pain patients differ
than dystonia patients right what are
the vulnerabilities there what is their
kind of lived experience like what might
we need to build into the research
process to make sure that they're kind
of treated in the right way
team constitution what does the research
team look like is there a high
prevalence of
surgeons who are also the lead
investigator how might that affect how
we approach patients we can talk about
that more in a bit
um are there non-clinicians on the team
right and
might that affect also what kind of
training we want to make sure the team
has are there tech companies in the room
during surgeries and so on
thinking about the relationship between
care and research so as we looked at
those four studies not only did they
kind of differ in their risk profile
maybe they also differ in invasiveness
you know that's a tricky concept to
think about
but they also differ in you know how
close in time and space
the clinical care of the patient is with
the research so
um again intraoperative
research is during a
a clinically indicated surgery but a bci
study
all of the clinical care is kind of
subsumed under the research so those
different relationships may also impact
ethical considerations
and lastly just for now um participant
levels of participant involvement and
kinds of participant involvement this is
something that my group just recently
started thinking about so
not just you know when are patients
signing up for research is it during a
surgery in the hospital in their emu
stay out of a out of the clinic
altogether
um
but what space are they in are they in a
clinical space um
would that you know contribute to
misconceptions about whether what
they're doing is part of their care or
part of research um and also the kind of
involvement the kind of involvement
involved in perhaps a intraoperative
research study where you're moving a
joystick
might be very different than the kind of
involvement of a of a five-year-long bci
study where participants are coming to
the lab twice a week for years um taking
a kind of active role in the in the
research process itself and that might
change the ethical landscape as well
so thinking about all these different
contextual features and kind of taking a
microscope to a group of studies that
may seem a bit homogeneous at first but
are actually quite nuanced and different
scholars and researchers have raised a
whole host of ethical concerns about
these types of studies and on the screen
you'll just see a list of some of those
it doesn't include everything
um
but these are all questions that have to
do not with what we can do but with what
we ought to do right so these are these
are how you might begin to answer that
question should we make use of these
opportunities to study the brain and my
lab in particular is interested in three
of these questions um the first is
acceptable risk benefit
ratio and we talked a little bit about
that before
um
but we're really interested in how we
make the determination
that the risks of some of this research
are worth
the knowledge benefits and that's a very
difficult determination to make because
on the face of it it compares things
that seem quite different you know risks
of harm to individuals
brains towards the benefit of learning
something about the brain
and we're very interested in the role
that patient perspectives can play in
coming to make
more inclusive
value judgments about that um we're also
interested in questions about disability
and justice right so how can we develop
technology so all of this research
involves neurotechnology right so how
can we develop neurotechnology that
doesn't kind of over pathologize
difference right that respects
neurodiversity that engages with the
disability communities who may make use
of this technology in the future um
we also think about
you know the fact that only patients
with disabilities and certain neuro and
psychiatric disorders can participate in
the research right so because you have
to have a clinical indication for
neurosurgery in the first place that
means all of this research is being done
on patients who
belong to various kind of
groups
and they may share a kind of disability
so how do our
judgments about even what risks are okay
right how are those things impacted by
how we think about disability and how we
think about the quality of life of
certain disabled individuals
um
lastly and the and the area that i'll
focus on for most of the rest of the
talk
um is questions about consent
and
um
those questions include things like can
participants freely
volunteer really for this type of
research and what would we have to do to
ensure that
so i'd like to just narrow our
topic down a little bit before i look at
the proposed framework and some patient
data
so let's look at consent and questions
about consent in in intraoperative
studies so just studies that take place
during a patient's
surgery
so
consent two you know two really
fundamental pillars of consent in
research ethics is that participation in
these studies be based on an informed
decision and that participation be
voluntary and i think thinking about the
particular context of intraoperative
studies raises questions for both of
these pillars so first we might ask
ourselves
um look these patients who are having
surgical interventions for dbs for you
know treatment resistant depression um
may
have some cognitive effects that may
make us worry that they don't have the
capacity to understand some of the
nuances of this research right
the research context might make us worry
about the capacity of particular
individuals to kind of weigh the risks
and the benefits in in the in a
reasonable way
thinking about what patients understand
independently of capacity right do
patients adequately understand the risks
of the study when those risks are maybe
difficult to quantify
do they understand the benefits do they
understand that this is completely
non-therapeutic do they understand the
goals of the study
how much do they understand the
separation of care and research right
this is a particular question for this
type
of research because the care and the
research are happening together so how
could we figure out whether patients
really understand that distinction
um thinking about voluntary
participation
many people have worried about undue
influence on enrollment right
particularly because
many of the surgeons who are in charge
of the clinical
intervention are also
the lead researchers in charge of the
research right and so you might worry
that this dual role can create a bit of
a conflict of interest both for
investigators but also impact patients
right who may feel pressure to enroll
because it's their surgeon who may worry
about you know impacts on their care if
they say no
um
and
you know
may kind of put a bit of a pre yeah i
don't want to say coercion but um you
know in many ways might kind of nudge
patients in ways that are problematic
for thinking about free consent
um the last topic here we'll talk about
at the end if we have time thinking
about the right to withdraw is also
really complicated and has garnered a
lot of attention in the neuroethics
community in these studies and i think
the most straightforward way to make
this point is that patients are in the
middle of a surgery when the research
happens many times they're awake but
their head is clamped down into a frame
and so literally they cannot get up and
leave and so then what does it mean
to really give them a meaningful you
know right to withdraw
so after kind of laying the landscape a
bit and probing you and hopefully making
you quite concerned
about the ethics of some of these
studies um i'd like to just probe a
little bit deeper if i haven't done it
already yet and and problematize the
issue of consent even further
so
on top of these kind of
abstract considerations there is
currently
no consensus on the best practices for
consent and recruitment in these studies
part of that has to do with the fact
that federal
recommendations kind of caution in one
way and irbs might
um you know kind of differ in their
approaches and so we kind of have a
bunch of differing
methods but i also think there's a real
kind of conceptual struggle not just
that you know studies are different and
so people are doing different things but
that we really quite don't know what to
do with this context so some of the
questions that remain
are things like practical questions so
who should do the consent should it be
the surgeon should it be a researcher
who's not a surgeon
should it be someone who's not involved
in the study altogether and what are the
reasons for and against those different
options and various research teams do it
differently
this has raised some people to be really
concerned about dual role consent and we
talked about this on the last slide so
you won't spend a long time here but
when you have the very same person who
has therapeutic responsibilities to a
patient but then also playing a role
with different responsibilities to the
patient how do you make sure there's not
a conflict of interest
how do you make sure that doesn't
undermine voluntariness and how do you
make sure that doesn't kind of promote
the therapeutic misconception so that's
um the the view that um the research
will benefit me so a view of patients
that the research will benefit me
um even when it won't right so this kind
of persistent misconception about how
research is related to care
um concerns about dual role consent have
led people like christine grady to
propose something else right so maybe
what we need is something like hybrid
consent maybe we need to separate the
surgeon from non-clinical researchers
and maybe the surgeon
you know participates in one part of the
consent explaining the risks and the
benefits after all they may be the
person who understands that the best
but then let's have a non-clinical
person come in and do the rest of the
consent answer questions about
withdrawing answer questions about
voluntariness and stuff like that
and that's garnered a lot of attention
and many labs do that
but even
if we settle
on you know okay we're we're gonna go
with dual role or we're not gonna go
with do roll there still are a whole
host of practical questions
that we need to answer and we need to
answer them for each individual study
so the questions that remain when is the
best time to consent a patient thinking
about this in the operating room or in
an intraoperative study
we might worry well
if we consent the patient too close
to the surgical consent they may not
really fully appreciate what's happening
in the research right the surgery may
kind of eclipse the research and there's
some data that suggests that this might
be the case
um
should there be on ongoing consent
process certainly for studies that take
you know five years and have multiple
points of patient involvement
ongoing consent is is doable and a very
good idea what do we do in this case
where the research is a kind of one-time
thing and it's happening during the
surgery
you might think look patients still will
accrue different information over time
and feelings about participation may
change even when they're in the or so
maybe we should explore re-consent
but if we do that
should they be approached multiple times
how many times at what intervals when
who should do the re-consent
does reconsent even make sense when a
patient is in the middle of surgery any
of the concerns that we may have had
about original consent
about undue influence about
understanding about the separation of
clinical care and research you could
imagine being even more concerned about
them in the middle of a brain surgery
right so we're left with these questions
and i won't take a long time i could go
on about this for forever i'll just do a
few more slides and then we'll move to
the last part of the talk
um
but of critical importance and i think a
place that really has not yet garnered
garnered enough attention is real
concrete recommendations for making the
right to withdraw real possibility in
the middle of a surgery
so
this is a this is a place where kind of
collaborative
um efforts are really important because
i think everyone in the audience here
would agree that the right to withdraw
is kind of a crucial cornerstone of
research ethics
but the challenge is how do we
carry out the duty that that right
generates in us as researchers and as
research teams in an intraoperative
setting if it's a negative right that
means
it just requires that researchers not
prevent somebody from withdrawing but of
course
it probably requires more than that it
might be a positive right which mean it
might require us in the research setting
to physically do things for patients to
make that a possibility and this might
be different in the or
versus in the emu where patients
literally cannot leave
one year into a bci study or an early
feasibility study patients have a device
in their head right so
making the right to withdraw a real
possibility probably means removing the
burden of of taking that device out
so in response to
this kind of really complicated set of
studies and really deep concerns about
consent
um
a group of more than 30 nih-funded
researchers
who participate and who conduct this
type of research
and myself
spent a long time trying to develop
a framework to help researchers reflect
on the practices of others and to
provide a kind of shared basic framework
for other people to
develop practices right have justified
practices within a community so this
framework was recently published in
neuron and i'm going to share a few of
the basic
principles of the framework and explain
a little bit about how to use it
um
so you'll see the author list is quite
large so i i like pointing that out um
not only is it quite large but there's
really only two ephesus in this group
the rest are really fun you know
scientists and neurosurgeons funded by
the brain initiative and
who make up the research opportunities
in human consortium and i'm happy to
talk about that in the q a
so the proposed framework really starts
by offering two very basic commitments
that should guide the the design and
implementation of basic human
intracranial research and the two
principles are here the first is
maintaining the integrity of clinical
care and space
and the second is ensuring voluntariness
of participation
i think these are interesting to offer
us kind of first principles
i don't know how many ephesus or
philosophers are in the audience but
number one is really fascinating
i think it reflects the unique
experiences and knowledge of
investigators that they know what it's
like to be in the space to be in the
surgical space to be in the research
space in a way that
ephesus may not and i think it's very
telling that that was their first
principle
prioritizing the integrity of clinical
care requires practices to ensure that
care is not compromised purposefully or
inadvertently so this you'll see when we
go to the next slide this principle is
meant to generate
a bunch of other um normative guidelines
about how to protect the clinical space
and in a way this principle says even
though we're doing research in the
clinical context um
clinical care is first right so we're
we're doctors first and researchers
second which is interesting
so the proposed framework um kind of
looks like this uh i'll i'll provide a
little flow chart in a second and give
an example of how to use it but it's
pretty straightforward it's the basic
commitment is on the left the middle
column is a set of kind of intermediary
principles that um
come out of that commitment so that
commitment would support or justify
the principles in the middle and then on
the right side you'll see just examples
from the investigators of current
practices that they
use
that they think are
kind of applications of that principle
and when you know sometimes the group
thought that they could use some new
principles some new practices right so
you'll see current practices and also
proposals for other things that they
think should deserve
research and effort into developing um
i think if you go across the top you can
see so maintaining the integrity of
clinical care and space supports
principle one which is that clinical
care and research should be uncoupled
such that care be neither compromised by
nor conditional on research
participation and this must be
communicated to patients
and then you want to carry that out into
specific practices so some of the things
researchers do that respond to this
principle
is they separate clinical and research
consent in time space and personnel so
it's not specific to how they do it
right that's interesting so but they
but it's one way that they do it right
but it doesn't say who's there and who's
not there at what time they do it but
that there's a separation in those
literal consent discussions
and proposed
practices
um number two is interesting proposing
the stan that standardized videos are
offered to provide a consistent external
voice describing the separation of care
and research
and so i think that's an interesting
proposed practice right letting someone
else kind of come in and provide a
neutral perspective for the patient to
kind of hear some of the risks and the
benefits of from as a way to mitigate
some of that influence
the second principle is the same kind of
table but it it outlines some principles
responsive to the importance of
voluntariness and then gives some
example practices that researchers use
and some proposed practices that they
would consider in the future and notable
um it's notable that some of the
principals
um don't have any current practices
associated with them but investigators
felt like we should have some and so
you'll see you know i think it's um
principle six there's only proposed
practices right consenting to research
may require different cognitive
decision-making capacities than
consenting to care
and consent protocols should reflect
this
no one had practices that reflected that
yet but they proposed some right so
additional intellectual capacity or
cognitive assessments or seeking
explicit confirmation of this
understanding of the goals and the risks
of the study
so um this is just how you might use
this in practice so you might be able to
make a flow chart for yourself of um
of
you know what practices you might need
to implement
um
depending on the type of research that
you do so you could use you could use
the framework two ways you could kind of
start from the commitment
walk down and
see what types of practices you think
you ought to implement or you could take
a practice that you already have and
work backwards and see whether it's
justified or falls under any of those
principles and commitments i think
importantly this is not an exhaustive
list of the commitments and the
principles and the practices
but it is a way to offer some kind of
structure to a group of studies that are
very different and very very
heterogeneity hetero
i can't ever say that word uh variable
there we go um
and i think
it
it's a very useful tool and
um a nice contribution to
this field
so
quickly we can highlight maybe what's
interesting about this proposal
again we mentioned this before so you
can go quickly it focuses on the duality
of the research context itself and not
just the duality of the role of the
researcher and that's notable because it
creates
um
it generates a sense of ethical
responsibility beyond the researcher
right so anyone who's in that or is in
us in a kind of dual space and so we may
need practices
and trainings and you know ways of
interacting with each other that respect
that that go beyond just the researcher
themselves
it kind of offers the beginning of a
standardized tool for ethics
without prescribing standardized
practices and i think that is a very
difficult thing to do it suggests that
what this type of research needs is a
kind of modular approach to thinking
about consent and thinking about
recruitment where we need the ability to
um really respond to all those different
nuances as remember that taxonomy that
we looked at before different patient
populations different vulnerabilities
but we could have some standardized tool
to help us navigate those those cases in
similar ways
it's a nice example of an ethical
collaboration between investigators
and
the proposal
calls for
patient participant input so if you read
the kind of paper or you look at some of
the other practices there really is a
focused attention on
more communication with patients
encouraging patients to talk with their
families finding more time to revisit
concerns
and i think that this leads quite nicely
into the last part of this
discussion which is really how do we
move from this framework which was very
much developed from the perspective of
investigators and what they experience
in this space to incorporating the
patient the patient experiences and the
patient values because if we don't quite
understand where patients are when
they're approached to participate or
what their concerns are
what what it's like to kind of
participate in this research
then
you know the framework is not going to
help right
i just want to quickly start by
highlighting a study
done by wexler and her group
published an american i think it was
american journal of bioethics empirical
and it's a study of 22
participants who
consented to join
intraoperative research during their dbs
implantation surgery
and they were consented for the research
and then five days before the surgery um
took place uh they participated in this
study to see how much they could recall
about informed consent right what did
they kind of remember about the research
at that point right so about a week
after they did inform consent but five
days before they were about to do it
um and here's the statistics right so
um
only 22.7
correctly recalled the study risks
um only 36.4 correctly recalled the
study purpose
only 50 percent
correctly recalled the study protocol
and 36.4
correctly recalled the study benefits
um
and i generally like to remain agnostic
about this type of data because it's a
small sample size and there's all sorts
of reasons you know why this might be
the case but at first glance that is
pretty shockingly low right and
not only that but it's like five days
before they're about to go into surgery
and then participate in research
so
part of my lab's work also interviews
patient participants and we have some
qualitative data from participants who
also who also joined intraoperative
research and so this is part of our rf1
dr peradian and myself are co-pis and we
interviewed 15 participants um who were
participating in research
during their surgery for parkinson's
dystonia epilepsy and across three
different types of research studies
and we found some similar things right
so we found very minimal concerns with
risks so here i'm going to share some
quotes from the patients with you i
didn't really think about that and
patients talking about risk if there was
a risk they would have stopped it or
they wouldn't have done something like
that i mean they wouldn't just keep
asking me questions if there were risks
no it didn't occur to me i personally
don't feel that i had any increased risk
in participating in the research
patients also expressed minimal
understanding of the study like the
wechsler paper as well i have no idea i
don't know what they were doing at all
maybe they're mapping the brain maybe
they're just training somebody how to
apply an electrode i have no idea i just
trust that somebody's getting something
out of it
i don't know what the heck i've
contributed to it but i feel good about
it okay
there's not a whole lot of information
out there on it so why not i like being
part of something obviously bigger than
myself
patients also express a real immediate
and ease to the decision to join so dr x
just asked nicely would you like to be a
part of this and i went sure it's a
study and it'll further knowledge that's
what i'm all about
dr x did say you can take a minute to
think about it and i was like i don't
have to just put me in the study
it was an easy decision for me i was
like yeah that's going to help someone
else absolutely i'll go for it
really importantly no patient
said anything that indicated that they
were under the therapeutic misconception
right so that they thought that the
research would benefit them or
that they thought it was going to impact
their care
and most cited the study is helping
others which is correct and um no one
regretted participating so patients
really you know they didn't
really care very much about the risk
or didn't know very much about the goals
of the study but in some sense they
weren't really confused they just
it's unclear what's happening right
as they kind of shared more about their
motivations for joining i think some
really interesting things came out that
could help guide how we use our
framework
um
to develop best practices so they shared
a lot about the importance of basic
brain research to them you never know
with the way research is they could find
a cure tomorrow or 10 years down the
road or they could never find the cure
but i feel as myself
being like a donor
if a part of my body can help save
somebody else that's great it may not
benefit me but it might benefit someone
down the road they talked about the
impact of their illness on motivations
to join doing things in the memory of
people that they had known that passed
away from their condition
and really citing the incredible
importance of being able to help others
the last thing that came out of this
interview these interviews that i in the
last two minutes that i want to share
because i think it's crucial in
developing best practices for consent
is the role that trusts played for these
patients
almost in talking about all aspects of
the study and i won't read all of these
quotes but you can look at them a bit as
i'm talking
um
i'll read maybe one or two
so
no i did of course trust him but i
didn't give it a great deal of thought i
just made the decision to participate
if i didn't trust him then i wouldn't
have agreed to have the surgery done at
all so if i'm trusting him with that and
if this is a way that can help anybody
dot dot dot
i think this is quite interesting so you
know what do we kind of make of all of
this um
i think
a controversial take would be something
like this um patients who are approached
to participate in research during
their surgery
think very little about the decision to
join they make it almost immediately
they will say yes likely very quickly
and perhaps with only a vague
understanding of the study goals and
very little concern with the risks
but they'll do so out of feelings of
robust trust and deference to their
doctor and an appreciation for the value
of basic science and helping others
so
what do we do with that how do we
translate that into any practical steps
about best practices
this is the next step that we're at in
my lab and i'm happy to share with you
kind of like our plans of how to mix
together investigators and patients and
you'll see we also have the public in
here
so for us the current steps and next
steps are integrating patient values
with practical proposals so thinking
about really proposing a formal
re-consent process during the surgery
right requiring formal opportunities to
withdraw during the surgery
thinking about having someone other than
the surgeon someone other than the
research team be kind of a part of these
conversations with the patient from the
beginning building that relationship
with a third party not just in the
middle of the surgery but from the
beginning
and thinking about practices that really
build trusting relationships as trust
was such a central feature of of why
participants are joining and what
they're thinking about as they assess
the risks and the benefits how can we
make sure that trust is not exploited
and that the clinical team and the
research team is really invested in that
trusting relationship
we'll move a little bit more quickly
through these so kind of further
exploration of patients
narratives so we're moving to interview
patients in the emu sitting interviewing
patients who have chronic implants
interviewing dci patients
also
further interviews with investigators
and surveys of the public the public has
a really interesting third kind of
perspective on some of these things
they're uninvolved in a way but they're
also a stakeholder how can we think
about what matters to patients by
comparing it to what matters to a kind
of uninvolved party
and then lastly
making progress on practical steps for
involving patients what what kind of
methodology should we be using when we
approach patients to participate in some
of these conversations
i'd like to end by just quickly noting
that um i think to answer all these
questions and i think you know i i hope
that the way we've discussed ethics
today has made you kind of believe this
too there's no way to answer these
questions and what we just talked about
today really without having an
interdisciplinary team and i think a lot
of people talk about you know embedding
ethicist into science as the kind of
standard but um we do both in our lab we
embed ephesus into science we observe
surgeries we go to lab meetings but we
also embed scientists into ethics right
so we we invite scientists to
participate in the discussions to write
the manuscripts and embed them in a
methodology and kind of take
responsibility for those arguments
and i think you know the philosophy of
our lab is really team building trust
and time we trust each other with
really critical stances towards the work
and we reflect a really genuine openness
about the possibility that some of this
research should not be done something
that i think is crucial to making
ethical progress in a space like
neuroethics
so with that um i have a few more things
on the on slides i'll let people look at
while i say my goodbyes um but thank you
so much for having me here today and i
look forward to discussing this with you
all in the question and answer period
thank you dr feinstein for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question
how are invasive brain technologies
managed once implanted in research
participants and there's a second part
what are some of the ethical
considerations applied for managing
these technologies outside of the
patient
yeah that's a really good question so
in the talk we focus mostly on you know
the the event where the technology gets
put in the patient but we didn't touch
on at all
of the host of ethical questions that
come up
when you think about and then what right
so
there's a large body of research on
post-trial obligations so what are the
obligations that
researchers or companies right who are
involved in developing this technology
have towards patients who
um either are users of the technology
for a therapeutic reason but who also
have kind of offered their brain for
science right who have part been part of
an early feasibility study or who have
participated in research that uses those
devices so this is a really good
question um
i think
at minimum the ethical considerations
that
researchers think about are things like
trying to maximize continued access
maintenance making sure that there's
resources in place so that patients who
have this technology
can
make sure it works
can get care um and
you know know about the possibility
that
that technology and those devices may
not be supported forever so especially
if you participate in a study where
the device is new
or the technique is due
um
that device may
you know may not be made forever and so
how can we make sure that patients are
prepared for that and that we don't kind
of leave them with devices in their head
that are not supported or that um you
know nobody kind of will
take care of so a lot of times it
depends on what study you're asking
about if you're if you're asking about
something like a bci study there'll be
very explicit discussions in the consent
process about explanation
um
but you may be asking a different
question which is something like
um
what do we do about um
you know how do we kind of
make sure the devices are developed in
appropriate
ways outside of the patient i think we
would have to ask a tech person that um
but i do think a crucial piece of that
puzzle again is to talk to patients what
are their expectations right after after
those devices are implanted in their
heads do they expect continued care do
they expect to still have access to
their surgeon
what are they thinking they're owed in
virtue of their participation that's a
great question
thank you so much
now what are the main psychosocial
characteristics of the volunteers for
invasive brain research studies
that is also a really good question
so um part of what part of how my
collaboration started with um with a
neurosurgeon was we were asking
questions about altruism we're asking
questions about
um what types of patients
want to volunteer for some of the
studies right so you you know if you
kind of surveyed the public or you had a
larger sample size
you may find that very many people would
not
want to participate in some of this
research and so how does that you know
how does that play into how we approach
patients um we don't i don't think that
anyone has done a robust study on this i
mean um
part of answering this question would be
to interview and talk to participants
who were approached
to enroll but didn't like declined and
that is part of our study as well so so
far we've only interviewed the patients
who um said yes for the intraoperative
research but um there are patients who
have been approached and good candidates
for the research that have said you know
no thank you i'd like to get my implant
be be done and on my way and so that
would be part of answering that question
um we have had some narratives for other
studies so we have a we've talked to
patients in an early feasibility um
study for a cortical prosthesis device
um
and
they
some of those patients have really
expressed kind of extreme altruism
really just in their lives being the
types of people that want to give back
to science and want to help others
so that's a crucial question and i would
say
um altruism is a is a big thing to study
that's a great question
absolutely and i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in
um
are the invasive brain research study
volunteers financially compensated at
and at what level
yeah that is also a really good question
um
it depends i would say so different
teams do things
differently
especially
for studies that are long term for
really highly involved studies bci
studies studies where patients are
really spending a lot of time coming
into the lab
and really being partners in the
research process
many teams do compensate and compensate
you know a significant amount for the
participants time and some teams feel
that compensation amounts to inducement
right so
if you
offer money
there's some level of money that's
that's okay but it's probably likely too
low and once you kind of raise that
level higher and higher some ephesus and
researchers really feel that you're
you're moving away from compensation and
you're moving towards kind of
incentivizing participation um i don't
think there's a consensus on this um so
that is a a serious area as well
that's a good question
we have one more question a couple
actually we have a couple questions mark
coming in
uh could a team for consent have
downsized such as increased patient
confusion decreased trust
higher cost
these are fantastic questions um
i would say it's possible
i think it depends how you do it right
so
increased um or having a team for
consent just for the purposes of having
a team and having more people and more
conversations i don't think would
would necessarily meet some of those
ethical benchmarks but providing
a really thoughtful
process
i think
would increase trust and decrease
confusion right so sometimes we think
you know providing opportunities for
patients to develop that trust with
multiple members of the team might be
really important
and as would providing a kind of
external person for the patient to
confide in if they had any concerns that
maybe they don't feel comfortable saying
to a clinician
but i do think that's a really good
point that just more people is not
necessarily better
there i think we really need some
focused research um dedicated towards
you know what practices would be would
be optimal that's a great point
thank you so much we have time for two
more questions what do you think
clinician researchers could do
specifically
to improve consent in
um intraoperative research
you know this is a good question too um
i think
as i mentioned in this in this talk
i really do think being quite explicit
during
the surgery about an opportunity to
withdraw i think we tend to think of
um
the intraoperative research as being
kind of a one solid chunk
but it can be 30 minutes long there are
multiple times to check in on the
patient there are multiple times to
really kind of remind them of that
opportunity and i think it can become
easy to assume
that patients will say they would like
to stop when they want to stop and
really we don't quite understand what
it's like for them to be in that
situation so i think being quite
explicit about opportunities to withdraw
even building it into their formal
consent
and um
being open to allowing more time for
consent conversations at the beginning
of the study as well
absolutely you have time for one more
question
our final questions about irb what do
you think irb should look like for
assessing content in practices for these
types of studies
yeah i have no idea actually
i think about that question i have no
idea i mean i think again this is an
area where research would be really
helpful to have some data about what
types of practices tend to correlate
with what types of attitudes and
decision-making processes but i think at
minimum again
looking for
thoughtfulness about re-consent looking
for thoughtfulness about withdrawing um
and looking for um consent and
recruitment processes that
are paying attention to
that that taxonomy that i propose like
who who is the patient population your
consent for
this patient population should probably
not look exactly the same as your
consent processes for a different one
um so yeah nuance um but also we
probably need research before i can
answer that question
absolutely dr weinsteiner it's been a
pleasure thank you so much for your
presentation today do you want to
provide the audience with any closing
remarks before we go
um this was just a wonderful platform to
have this discussion i know this is a
neuroscience conference and so i really
think it's wonderful
ethics conversations and um
i i do think that
when we have these conversations
together it pushes the field forward in
wonderful ways so i'm just glad to be a
part of it and thank you
absolutely well we thank you again for
your time and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our seeker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until 2024 march elaborates will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
bye-bye
you